what brought you to hillsdale this time
i'm giving a speech tonight on satire
comedy um
basically just we're in such a humorless
world and we're in such a humorous state
right now as a society what is why why
do we need to laugh it's something we've
lost as a culture you know i don't know
it's something where
the children know better than we do
because as a society we've kind of
decided that
we've decided that humor is not that
important or
it should only make fun of certain
things or it's you know humor
only has a specific place in culture and
i think i think it's just um it's
something where as a society we really
need to and as conservatives as
something we need to reclaim i think you
know and
as conservatives we
we kind of seeded that ground i think we
seeded the culture more in a lot of ways
and we we gave it up
um
so i don't know i'm being too
pretentious here no you're okay so why i
tell you you
talk about conservatives specifically
yeah as conservatives we have lost that
why okay so there's a couple of elements
here conservatives and christians we
tend to take ourselves very seriously
because we're fighting for and defending
very important things and as part of
that we throw the baby out with the
bathwater and we say well we then we
cannot make fun of anything or we can't
make fun of ourselves or we can't make
fun of our silly hypocrisy or traditions
that have come along with the very
important things that we're defending so
that's
that's an element i think um also
conservatives and i come from a
protestant background and so
protestants especially
we don't see art and especially comedy
as an end in itself so that's what the
left has done so well is the left wants
to communicate like an existentialist
worldview and all this stuff and the way
they do that is by making uh frozen
you know which you don't watch and go oh
this is communicating an existentialist
worldview you just watch it and go oh my
kids love this song and they sing along
and it's just a very well done movie
very well animated very funny
but they're communicating worldview
through it
and their primary goal in making a movie
like that is to make a good movie they
just make a good movie and their
worldview happens to be a part of it
we always have to have our stuff make a
point and i think that's very bad for
comedy like comedy should just be funny
so with the babylon b it seems like you
are trying to make a point or are you
just trying to be funny a little bit of
both like i don't because again like you
you look at you look at um
you look at art from the left and it
does make a point
it's just that's not all it does and
that's not the primary thing it does
and so like when you look at something
like the babylon b where it's um you
know we we publish eight articles a day
we you know maybe 50 articles a week
it's
you're going to have ones that are
that are going more for a point you're
going to have ones that are more like
okay we're trying to communicate
something here
we know that most of our audience agrees
with this point and we want to give them
something that they can share and say
you know
i'm gonna give them something they can
share and go here's uh here's what i
believe
or something that just makes them not
feel so alone like that's another great
thing that comedy does is is we can
laugh at something then they go you too
like you're not i'm not the only one who
believes this you know and that that's
important i think especially for
conservatives right now
but i mean the best comedy is you know
we wrote one
a few years back where we said that
anti-wall extremists the kool-aid man
leads campaign against trump and he's
mad at trump's wall because he likes to
break down walls and it was great
because that was a great example of an
article where
people on the left thought we were
making fun of trump and people on the
right thought we were doing endearing
satire of trump that was maybe making
fun of the left you know for being so
opposed to his wall
so it was something where you had you
had thousands of people sharing it on
both sides of the aisle and it i mean it
diffuses the tension around the
conversation it
makes people laugh it
um
maybe it does communicate something in
there or in the article maybe it doesn't
i don't know i don't really care it made
people laugh you know
and so i think when we look at the kind
of satire we do some jokes are gonna get
people laughing they're they're pacing
jokes they don't they don't necessarily
need to make a point and then when we do
make the point
they're already disarmed they're already
laughing you know so they're much more
willing to listen to your point of view
at that point i think you mentioned
eight articles a day about 50 a week
yeah what are some of that's a lot yeah
to produce
what are some of your favorites that you
have
produced
the thing is it's like
i'm always thinking about the next joke
so every time a comedian writes a joke
you think it's your last one you're ever
going to come up with in your life you
know
that's it that's all i've got
i remember about a few months into the
life of the bee i wrote an article and i
was and i was struggling to come up with
another one and i thought well that's it
like i'm out of juice i got nothing else
you know
and i've been saying that every day for
five years you know so that's
the comedian is always thinking about
the next joke like what's the next thing
i can do you're always looking at
situations in that way i mean
[Music]
if i were to pick out some favorites
like we wrote the one during the during
the pandemic we wrote um
celebrities spell out we're all in this
together with their yachts and we had
this like beautiful photoshop of all of
all of the yachts and the boats and it
got fact checked people thought it was
real you know
um
and it was we made fun of um that was a
fun one because we made fun of patton
oswalt in it and
he because he had made some comment
about you know the poor the poor people
you know
basically making fun of people for being
unemployed during the pandemic yeah and
he didn't realize how insensitive he was
sounding so we put a small joke about
him in the article and then he shared it
and he goes this is pretty funny i gotta
admit but he made fun of me but i
appreciate it we didn't even know that
he knew who we were you know
and that's a good example of something
where
you can make fun of somebody and you
know they're disarmed in some way right
like they're they're
they're they're laughing and they
understand that it's not done in this
super mean way you know at least good
comedy
i think it's like we were talking
earlier about how it humanizes people
and so if i think it brings people
together because you know it's taking
everybody down good comedy it's taking
everybody down and so it's kind of
leveling the playing field right good
comedy deconstructs i mean not always
like there's obviously different kinds
of jokes but the
good comedy deconstructs um like systems
right so you make fun of an entire
the political process you know you make
fun of we'll make jokes that make fun of
democrats and republicans in one
headline um we did a joke saying that
congress congress is going to have bar
codes printed on their heads so that um
lobbyists can just self-check out you
know they can just scan them and do
self-checkout
you know and it's something where both
people can enjoy that everybody can
laugh at that you know we had
people that are close to congress who
were sharing that and laughing about it
you know so
um yeah i think a good joke deconstructs
the system and
well and and that's an essential element
of comedy too is that
everybody's coming at things from one
angle
even from the right like we obviously
write comedy a lot from the perspective
of the right but
if we just keep parroting the same
perspectives that everybody else is
saying on twitter or whatever then it's
not funny like no matter how
clever our particular angle is like we
need to be um
we need to be coming at it from
one of my uh one of my co-writers at the
bambomb calls it the third angle you
have to find the third angle because
everybody's doing this and this
like if you come at it from an
unexpected angle
you want people to go i've never thought
about it that way before you know and
you maybe you can make your point
somewhere in the copy or whatever it
doesn't if you want to make a point
but it really should come at it from
that third angle i think as much as you
can and what is the
idea process you go through to try to
train yourself to look for that third
angle every single day that's tough i
mean it's
i mean i wish there was a magic bullet i
wish there was you know some way to uh i
wish there was some way to just
generate headlines you know i actually
wrote i wrote a an ai script that
generates babylon b headlines for us and
it's really funny because it
you know like an ai doesn't get
it gets every element like i was like
alexandria ocasio-cortez
is a [ __ ] you know and does this stupid
puts her foot in her mouth and you know
whatever yeah walks off a cliff because
she's a [ __ ] you know but there's like
an essential something missing you know
that it doesn't understand so a good
joke like you can't
a good joke
you almost can't explain it
you have to experience it and you have
to you know i always kind of say it's
like you just have to glance at it and
look away you know there's like
you can't stare at it too long and
that's part of my the struggle with my
job is like i have to i read hundreds
hundreds and hundreds of headline
submissions you know every day and so
it's like you get numb to it after a
while
so
but at the same time that means i see so
many that when one does hit you you go
that's probably really good you know
um
but yeah trying to put yourself in the
headspace of
people who are scrolling on twitter and
facebook
and are they going to find this funny
are they going to find it shocking
an essential element of
our kind of comedy is that it looks like
a news headline right
the way that people consume news now you
know
backing up a little bit you know the
when the onion used to write
when the onions started they were they
were a published you know satirical
paper the physical piece of paper you
would go get
and though
the way that is consumed is very
different from the way news is consumed
today so the onion can write a headline
like
dog barks at evil you know and that's
not funny on your twitter feed or your
facebook feed but it was very funny in
the context of your reading this
satirical newspaper that has a joke
about bill clinton and it has a joke
about you know george bush or whatever
and then in the and then there's a
little like local column and it says dog
barks at evil and there's like a dog
growling you know in that context it's
very funny in our context people are
scrolling
and you really need something that is
going to be a topic they're interested
in it's got to be
usually got to be a current event it's
got to really jump out and they got to
be
you know people just do scroll nowadays
on twitter and they're like trying to
see what you know whatever the current
event is and they're going through and
what's what's the most horrible news
that's coming out today and so for us
what we want to do is kind of slip in
there into the cracks you know and we
see
and you're starting to read a headline
and you're mad you're already mad and
you're reading about how bad things are
in afghanistan or in washington dc
and then we have a little twist at the
end of the headline that makes you laugh
and that shocking element i think is
really what makes
makes our kind of comedy work so that's
always what i'm looking for is that kind
of shock you know at the end of it not
shocking in the
crass way or a rude way but in a you
know like oh wow you know that's
interesting so have there been headlines
that have stuck out to you that you've
loved and then just have not had good
reception all the time i mean that's you
know
you know the best the best baseball
players hit three out of ten you know
and that's
that would be very good for a comedian
to be able to write three out of ten for
our comedy right for us to be able to
get three out of ten that are hits you
know our very best writers you know do
about that and uh
so you're always trying to get in the
headspace of where people are at and
then you publish something and it's
always obvious in hindsight you go oh
obviously that wouldn't have done as
well as i had hoped you know yeah i mean
the ones that don't do well that i think
are hilarious are always
ones that are not political that are
just making fun of something really
stupid or off the wall or they're making
or they're you know they're
self-referential we're riding them from
a place where we're parodying our own
world view if we make fun of the right
they're never never going to do well
with our audience
but we'll still keep writing them
because they're funny and i think it's
important
um
there's you know making fun of everyday
life is really important
gk chesterton wrote that
the problem with journalism is that it's
necessarily focused on exceptions
so he was right so what he was saying
was
journalism has to
by its nature tell you how bad things
are and it tells you about things that
are not common so if you read the news
every day you're starting to think that
everybody's dying and all this
you know he says what the news doesn't
do is it doesn't tell his specific
example was the news doesn't tell you
here's all the silverware that was not
stolen last night you know it doesn't
report on the fork that is still in your
drawer in the morning it doesn't report
on
uh the millions of marriages that are
still going strong you know that's not
in the news and so one fun thing about
what the babylon be what the onion did
before us and the wittenberg door before
it did before then what we do now is
that it
we can look at everyday life and we can
write the article that your fork was not
stolen in your drawer that kind of thing
that points people to these like
everyday miracles of life and it's like
i don't know it really in some way
satirical news can give you a more
accurate portrayal of the world because
we can give you the things that are not
exceptions where news has to be about
death counts and this
freak you out you know how would you
define satire
well i mean it turns a very broad
range of things you know we'll talk
about like what is satire like
everything from
airplane and
uh best in show and spinal tap and
can
satirize but it can center as a wide
range of topics within you know in any
little comedy bit you write any little
joke you write can satirize something or
another
so satire satire is
often associated with like cutting you
know
it's a cutting tool it's a cutting
instrument
and so for me i think of satire as
a cutting instrument that helps us to
separate
what is important from what is not
so as you know we we write a lot of uh
jokes focused on the church and focused
on uh christianity and making fun what
we make fun of is modern christianity
and modern uh evangelicalism
you know and we'll get people that are
mad about that like why are you making
fun of christians so much but what we're
doing is we're not making fun of like
that the bible is important or the the
bible is true or that god is real you
know or that jesus is real and you know
we should follow him and all these
things that we actually believe
what we're doing is making we're making
fun of the way that people implement
that in their lives hypocrisy is a great
target for satire
um
you know one of the very first articles
we wrote was uh well the first article i
wrote for the babylon b the day it
launched was the
holy spirit unable to move through
congregation as fog machine breaks
you know and i got we and we actually
had angry like we had like uh you know
watcha bloggers coming after us for that
one like how dare you make fun of the
holy spirit you know and it's like
machine well what it's doing is it's
cutting away and it's saying like hey
uh this you know the these modern
elements of worship that we've
incorporated
into our understanding of the faith are
not
the core of the faith and it helps us to
cut that away and he does it in a loving
way you're not saying like you don't
write this like three thousand word
think based on why fog machine wi-fi
machines are evil
you just do it in this way where people
go oh you know i see what they're doing
there and people who go to churches that
have fog machines and laser light shows
and stuff they can laugh at it
in a way that
if they were if you were to just write
this like long angry thing but they
would not listen to you at all
so yeah it has an interesting way of
communicating a point while being funny
i think
do you think there's something
specifically about the like cancel
culture whoa culture that we have today
that makes the babylon bee
successful do you think it would be as
successful
i don't know 20 years ago than it is now
i mean
it yeah i don't think so i think the
battle lumbee hit hit at the exact right
time
i think i got this from a comedian who
came on our podcast once
he pointed out this absurdity that
the left controls the culture right now
they control the center of culture they
have won the culture war
the left controls so many of our
institutions and you know has has
infiltrated them and now and corrupted
them and now controls them
and yet they think they're oppressed
that that is that that is the
fundamental
division between
that is the fundamental hypocrisy in the
left right now is that they they think
that they're the oppressed ones and yet
they're they're the power you know so
people talk about things in comedy like
you have to punch up yeah which is you
know you got to make fun of people in
power and so then they'll come after the
battle on p and say well you guys don't
make fun of people you know you make fun
of the lgbtq community that's
we're like no that's the power that is
the power right now and that's what's so
funny is that they they think that
they're so oppressed but you have rich
you have rich white kids growing up
thinking that they're the most impressed
people on the planet which is a very
funny funny thing
i mean wokeness we just wrote a whole
book on wokeness that you know we we
put together in a month because we're
there's so much content there like we're
just
it's almost like it's just spilling out
of us because there's so much to talk
about and how do you make fun of all
that and i mean it's a blessing and a
curse it's a double-edged sword because
it's very hard to write comedy in the
current year because reality is funnier
than satire yeah how do we stay ahead of
it you know at the same time it's i mean
it's a target rich environment
speaking of reality being funnier do you
guys also have the not the bee which is
reality
can you tell me how that came about well
that's basically it because the news is
so funny right now that you have to be
constantly reminded that this is not
satire you know
and so there's so much material out in a
lot of ways it's easy for them because
they can just look at a headline and i
mean obviously like there's a lot of
skill involved in like picking what to
cover and like
an interesting headline is really hard
to write even from a real news
perspective to grab people
um and so they so they struggle with
that every day trying to like frame it
in an interesting way and what are
people and what are people on the right
interested in reading um
but then for us it's like we have to
look at a crazy story and then go how do
we top them how do we
i don't know like how do you go one step
further how did the bee start how did
you get involved in it it was kind of a
wild story my uh
wild and boring at the same time right
i was basically i was working a job in
the construction supply industry so very
boring and uh my uh my facebook on my
facebook feed i saw adam ford who um
who drew a christian webcomic and he
announced i'm launching the babylon bee
and in a lot of ways it was like
why has this never existed before this
and i immediately knew exactly what he
was doing you know
and it was like and the possibilities
started flooding my mind like
there's so much we could do with this
you know and you know i wrote primarily
christian jokes at first and moved more
into the political stuff
as the christian jokes dried up a little
bit but
i just emailed in a joke
and he replied at the end of the day and
said something like he's like i have
read thousands and thousands of
submissions today because it was just
instant he just instantly got flooded
he's like this was one of the only good
ones wow
and i uh and so then he said you can
write another one if you want you know
of course i'm already thinking like i'm
already out of jokes you know but i sent
another one the next day and then
another one the next day then i started
writing so i started writing about three
or four articles a day and i did that
for two years
and uh
i i would just send them in the morning
and go to my job and go about my life
and then
i decided to take the leap a couple
years later and i quit my job to take
over the site as editor-in-chief
full-time
um but yeah i mean
it was a little bit of a cultural
phenomenon just right away you know in
that
you know we bought a adam bought a 50
web domain and
and just we started riding satire in our
garages you know and that was
that was the battle on b i think it it
hit a cultural void
and what is their story behind the name
why i mean babylon i think of the bible
connotation yeah
that is the idea i mean i and i always
tell this story and then i started
thinking about it i was like i never
really asked adam
why
but for me what it means is
babylon is i mean that's where israel
was in exile you know so
for the jews to be in exile was i mean
imagine that life you you're god's
chosen people and you're not even in the
promised land you know and that's how it
feels for us as as christians especially
as conservative christians a lot of
times like we're
we don't feel like we're in the promised
land very often and
so the idea was that we're writing
dispatches from babylon and um the bee
thing is is great because you know we
yeah obviously it sounds similar it's
got the nice double beat and then uh
it was just taken from the sacramento
bee or any any newspaper name it sounded
good um
and uh you know it's got a stinger so
that yeah that's nice
a little bit a little bit of sting to it
but uh yeah i think it actually
originally was going to be named
something
he almost named it uh
something very generic it was like you
know christian daily news or something
something that was just would not have
taken off you know not memorable it's
not memorable and it's not and it was so
narrow like you could never expand
beyond that
beyond like i'm going to tell worship
leader jokes every day you know like
never being able to and now i mean you
know people people will ask about the
shift more into politics and it's like
we always wanted our our art to speak to
the world like
good good art does speak to a culture
and that's what christian art has done
for centuries you know it has
not just talked to christians it's like
it should influence culture you know so
for us to be able to do that
the name was and the name was an
essential part of it you know absolutely
how do you persevere
you said you've been doing it for about
five years
you mentioned that comedy is hard yes
how do you
you know stay strong in this
culture and then having to compete every
single day
i mean you're it's like i was saying
before about like what my favorite joke
is it's like the next joke is always
keeping you going like you're writing i
could throw one up right now
that's going to get thousands of
retweets and shares and that's great and
then after that initial rush of like
yeah this joke's doing well you're
always like hmm like what's
what else are people
talking about like what else can we
comment on how can we like how can we
slip in our joke
and fit it around all the all the crazy
things that are happening today so
i mean there's that i also think there's
you cannot worry too much about the
reception and like i was saying about
the jokes that i like that are my
favorites they don't do well
we just started writing a uh we created
a a
toddler
character who writes op-eds for us
and he reviews things so he's like
supposed to be kind of a pretentious
critic but he's three
you know so he reviews like uh coco
melon you know youtube channel all the
kids watch he reviews ketchup you know
like
it's just
it's never gonna do that well on social
media it's never going to have the
cultural influence of one of our big
political headlines that comments on
something
but
but because i love it i don't care
you know you can't write you can't just
write satire and go i want to write this
so that it'll get thousands of shares i
want to write this because people will
agree with it like that's going to get
tiring and then when the likes and
shares and retweets don't happen you're
going to be depressed about it
so you have to really balance it out
with like i'm going to write something
that only i am going to like i'm writing
this for me like i'll write a joke about
my wife
it's something very specific that
happened with me and her and i'm like
she's going to love this
nobody else likes it you know it gets
five shares on facebook
but i think that's i mean that's an
essential element like good comedy in a
lot of ways good comedy is like an
objective thing it's it's just
objectively funny and i don't care if
anybody else thinks so
i'm ahead of my time
do you take a lot of inspiration from
your family and your kids oh yeah all
the kids are just kids are so great just
you have such a great sense of humor you
have to i mean you have to have a sense
of humor about yourself
you know i got three boys and i was like
it's wild
um
chesterton had a great
chesterton had a great essay on i think
it's called on chasing after one's hat
and he talks about how
we have to see ourselves not as the star
of this great drama and that we are very
serious people but we have to see
ourselves as a star of a comedy
and uh he gives the example of a of a
you know british gentleman whose hat is
blown off by the wind and he chases him
and uh
the british guy who chases his hat and
is mad about it is the great butt of a
joke right because everyone's like
laughing at him but the one who thinks
of it like i'm i'm in a slapstick comedy
right now and chase is having a great
time and has a much better outlook on
life and a much better perspective and
that's
so that's a phrase we use a lot at the b
offices is we're just chasing our hats
you know
everything's going wrong or you know
whatever we're not getting the shares or
the clicks or whatever it's you know
we're chasing our hats
they'll cut you down to size for sure
yeah all across the board you know my
kids know i write comedy on the internet
and it's like i'll show them one of my
videos or i'll show them my joke and
it's like that's not funny you can
really okay well
if you say so i trust you
what is the greatest thing that you hope
that the bee does accomplish
what the babylon bee did
and i hope continues to do is that it
created you know
to create a brand is something that
can outlast you you know it's like
batman like the the symbol outlast bruce
wayne right so that's kind of that's
kind of what i see is that
if we can kind of create this movement
of like comedians that aren't afraid to
tell jokes that people don't want you to
hear
um they can comment on the news every
day you look at the onion as an
institution it's like the onion has
outlasted its founders and its writers
and
it has a new team of writers now
probably almost everybody was running
for the onion i didn't write for the
onion 25 years ago and it's the same
thing with what we're doing
you know we want it to outlast us you
look at most christian comedy and it's
based around a person or a personality
and if that person were to have some
crazy scandal or they stopped doing it
it's like it's done it's dead
um
you know but with the babylon b it's
like we can outlast that you know and we
can continue to provide we can continue
to speak truth to a post-truth culture
you know in
the in a way that like adam ford kind of
doesn't isn't really that involved with
the site anymore someday i won't be
involved as much with the site anymore
and my successor won't be involved with
that anymore but it's something that we
can
i don't know i'm really hoping that we
can we can kind of create this movement
of comedians that aren't afraid if it
makes you feel any better i didn't know
your name until
i knew the battle on b i read it all the
time but i didn't know the name
i kind of love to hear that because i
don't want it to be associated with me i
want to i want to die and be forgotten
you know i want i want i i would love in
30 years for people to still know what
the babylon bee is
let us pray
yes
started with this prayer
where's the altar called
[Music]